many of y'all are probably familiar with
the term evolution and some of y'all i'm
guessing are also familiar with the term
natural selection although it isn't used
quite as much as evolution and what
we're going to do in this video is see
how these are connected but we're also
going to address some potential
misconceptions that folks have about
evolution
so when a lot of people think of
evolution they think of a diagram or an
image that looks something like this
they can see what they would consider to
be a more primitive ancestor evolving
into a more sophisticated a more modern
type of organism and this is going from
some type of primitive ape all the way
to human beings
now there's some aspects of this diagram
that give the right idea that evolution
is the phenomena that organisms over
time can evolve can change in their
traits that can actually become
different species now the one thing
about this diagram that might be
misleading is is calling this character
primitive and somehow imagining that
this one in the front is better or more
advanced evolution doesn't necessarily
go from good to bad or primitive to
advanced it's really just continual
change based on what is most suitable
for the environment in which the
organisms are in
and this can take millions of years for
example the common ancestor of human
beings and other apes like chimpanzees
or gorillas can be 5 10 million plus
years in the past but it can also happen
right before our eyes for example every
year we have a new flu virus because the
flu virus is constantly evolving through
mutation
we have the coronavirus and we're having
new variants of that it seems like
almost every few months that is
evolution happening right before our
eyes but the key question is how does
this actually happen does the dna know
to change into something else well
clearly not the dna is not sentient it
is not somehow constructing itself and
that's where natural selection comes
into the picture
so let's imagine a population and i'm
going to think about a very abstract
population of these little circle shaped
things and an important characteristic
for evolution to happen is that you need
variation in the population and we talk
about variation we're talking about
different expressed traits
and you might ask where does that
variation actually come from well it's
going to come from mutation i talked
about variation when we think about
viruses the flu virus or the coronavirus
and it can also come from sexual
reproduction and we go into a lot of
detail in other videos how sexual
reproduction mixes and matches all of
the potential alleles that are in a
population so that different members of
the population are getting different
combinations of those alleles and so
that contributes to variation
and now variation by itself does not
lead to evolution you need variation and
selection pressure and this is really
where the term natural selection is
coming from what do i mean by selection
pressure well in this little example
here if these circles and triangle
looking things could just keep
reproducing they could find as many
resources as they need there's no
shortage of food there's no shortage of
environments in which they can live and
reproduce they had no predators well
you're not going to have selection
pressure and so all of these variations
might have an equal chance of living
their life and then reproducing but now
let's introduce some selection pressure
and imagine what might happen let's say
we introduce the selection pressure of a
predator
that has a much easier time seeing
seeing
white
well then what's going to happen
well over time generation of generation
the white circles and triangles here are
going to be much more likely to be eaten
by that predator before they can
reproduce and pass on the allele or the
alleles that might result in this white
trait and so next generations or future
generations are going to have fewer and
fewer of these white shapes so the next
generation might look a lot like this
a lot more of the purple
we're seeing and a lot more of
of the blue
now on the other hand you could have a
scenario where instead of a predator
that sees white and can't see the other
color showing up where there's a
shortage of food so that's another form
of selection pressure
let's say a more triangular shape
is useful
for finding food
for
food
well then what's going to happen well
generation by generation the shapes that
are more triangular are going to have a
better chance of surviving and
reproducing and so maybe in the first
generation you have maybe something like
that does reasonably well something like
that could do very well something like
that would do well
something like this could do well but
we're going to see we might see a few of
the circles still we might see a few of
these characters but we'll see fewer of
them and we're going to see more of
these characters right over here and now
you can imagine if this environmental
pressure continues then over generation
and generation you keep selecting for
more triangular if you could go forward
many hundreds or thousands or hundreds
of thousands or millions of years you
might see some subset of this population
that lives in this environment they
might have a very triangular shape they
might not even look anything like their
ancestors now does this mean that this
shape right over here is somehow more
advanced or better than what their
ancestors saw or maybe there's a cousin
species that was where the predators see
white and the triangular shape really
doesn't help you and so they have a
cousin species that looks like this
there's no way of saying that this
species is more advanced or better than
this species but what we can say is it
is more fit for its environment and this
species is more fit in its environment
so i will leave you there and it's
important to realize this isn't some
magical process it's all due to
variation caused by mutation and sexual
reproduction selection pressure and then
that change happens over time and this
isn't just something that happens over
millions or tens of millions of years it
happens before our eyes every day when
we talk about the different flu strain
or a different coronavirus strain or
drug resistant bacteria it's very
relevant to our day-to-day lives